as you deck the halls with boughs of
holly joe biden wants you to know that
we are not headed into the season to be
jolly but rather
into a winter of severe illness and
death
it's here now and it's spreading and
it's going to increase
for unvaccinated
we are looking at a winner of severe
illness and death unvaccinated
for themselves their families and the
hospitals they'll soon overwhelm
so lest you think that joe biden is just
projecting here what he's saying is it's
a it's a winter of severe illness and
death specifically for the unvaccinated
and the thing is none of that would
appear to be true from the evidence we
have right now so far according to the
cdc
just 43 people in the united states have
come down with the omicron variant of
coronavirus
nearly 80 percent of them were
vaccinated not unvaccinated vaccinated
one briefly went to the hospital no one
so far has died never mind that all
available evidence suggests that the
omicron or whatever whatever the next
one is that we're going to call it is
significantly milder than delta alpha
phi beta kappa all the other ones that
we know about no no no
you need to be afraid because otherwise
joe biden won't have as much power i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from felipe
potter who says
if you say that a teacher can teach
whatever he wants in the classroom
because he has freedom of speech
you also have to go wherever a bus
driver wants to take you because he has
freedom of movement this is such
a great analogy for so-called academic
freedom
the teacher i guess has the right to
think about whatever he wants to think
about
i guess he has the right to read the
kind of books he wants to read generally
speaking has the right to read but he
doesn't have the right to teach whatever
he wants he has to do his job and his
job involves teaching certain things and
giving his kids a certain kind of
education means teaching the truth it
means teaching things that are good it
means exposing students to things that
are beautiful and not the opposite of
all that just like a bus driver might
have the right to go wherever he wants
but not while he's on the job these are
basic things but our society does
doesn't understand basic things anymore
which is why you probably want to get
your hands on some tangible assets such
as acre gold acre lets you subscribe to
gold bars for as little as 30 dollars a
month don't call me a liar i know you're
because you're thinking that gold costs
more than 30 a month sure i know it does
but acres got this ingenious way of
having you subscribe when your gold
stash reaches the price of their gold
bars they will discreetly ship acre gold
to your house if you want to up the ante
they've got a 100 a month subscription
to a 5 gram gold bar i really like it
great way to to invest without coming
out of pocket all at once i have very
much enjoyed investing in physical
precious metals i've enjoyed my acre
gold i would really recommend you take a
look into it head on over to get acre
gold dot com slash knowles canada wles
right now start investing in physical
gold today make sure you go to that url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
merry christmas
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient and
mention at get underscore acre that is
get acre gold dot com slash knowles
be afraid be very very afraid
that is the message from joe biden
this is the kind of fear-mongering i
have never seen in my whole life in
american politics
having lived through 9 11
the wars in the middle east
trump talking about immigration
there's been a lot of
i guess you just caught you'd call it
fear-mongering i guess and then on the
other side you've got the democrats
fear-mongering about the russia scandal
and ukraine and all that other stuff
i've never seen anything like this the
president of the united states saying if
you don't do exactly what i tell you to
do and inject yourself with some
experimental drug then there's going to
be severe
pain illness death everywhere
by the way on the vaccines
turns out turns out the vaccines might
not be quite as safe as some of the
establishment wants you to believe
before you take me off the air youtube
and facebook and twitter whatever i'm
just
quoting the cdc
at yesterday's meeting of the advisory
committee on immunization practices cdc
officials
went into detail
on the blood clotting-related syndrome
that was identified in 54 people in the
united states who got the shot before
the end of august
okay
the fda earlier this week
said basically the same thing i'm just
reading directly from the fda report
here
cases of tts cases of blood clots
following the administration of the
johnson johnson
covid19 vaccine have been reported in
males and females in a wide age range of
individuals 18 years and older
with the highest reporting rate
approximately one case per 100 000 doses
administered in females ages 30 to 49
years
over so first of all
that's not nothing one in a hundred
thousand is not nothing when you're
talking about giving this vax to 330
million people overall
approximately 15
of the tts cases have been fatal
so you got 330 million people just about
getting the vaccine
in the specific age group you're looking
at one in a hundred thousand or getting
this this complication and then 15 of
that you die
that's not good
currently available evidence supports a
causal relationship between tts the
blood clots and the jansen
covid19 vaccine that's just from the the
fda
if you're going to take me off the air
for saying that then
you're then at least let's be honest you
are going to take me off the air
for quoting directly from an fda
report
obviously there are risks from the
vaccine despite all from the vaccines
plural despite all of the establishment
propaganda that this is 100 safe and
there's no risk whatsoever that's bs
there is risk in any vaccine and
basically any medical intervention you
take
and
sometimes the risks are higher and
sometimes the risks are lower
which is why from the beginning on these
vaccine issues
i have pointed out that there are
some prudential arguments to get the
vaccine despite the
medical and religious and moral
complications of it
and there are some prudential arguments
for not getting the vaccine and it might
vary even person to person
but
the fda and the cdc
saying yeah actually this maybe this is
a little bit worse than we thought yeah
now that both both bodies might say but
you should still get the vaccine but
that's just they're just explaining the
facts maybe there is more risk here even
the new york times covered this right so
then
the new york times covered it and then
they realized they had a little too much
truth in their headline so they had to
change the headline so the original
headline was a cdc panel weighs the
risks of blood clots linked to the j and
j vaccine okay that's pretty honest
right the cdc panel is looking looking
once again because there's more people
who have gotten these blood clots and
died from the blood clots okay so
they're going to raise away the risks of
of that vaccine
new headline
the cdc recommends that other vaccines
be preferred over j and j so they take
out the idea of risk they take out the
idea that maybe these things aren't
going to be totally safe for you
and they say no just maybe go look at
the other vaccines but the there are
risks from the other vaccines as well as
the cdc has admitted risks of
myocarditis risks of pericarditis in
different groups of people specifically
in younger men
but the establishment doesn't want
too much truth to get out they're trying
to hide this story
and this is why
when you don't believe the
legacy media when you don't believe dr
fauci when you don't believe big pharma
who the hell ever thought it was a good
idea to just blindly accept whatever big
pharma tells you
remember when
when people on the left thought that big
pharma was
maybe a little corrupt and maybe there
were some conflicts of interest here and
maybe we shouldn't just accept every
single one of their press releases as
gospel truth
and then kovit happened and now we're
told that big pharma is the greatest
most wonderful innocent
industry in america you remember that
i my friend ryan long the comedian made
this point
it was the left saying i hate big pharma
except for pfizer i love pfizer is
amazing pfizer's one but all the rest of
big pharma is really terrible so they're
all trying to hide the story which means
you got to do your own research and
you've got to make your own decisions
and you've got to use your own faculties
of reason and judgment and prudence
and i'm not sure you're even allowed to
say that anymore no consequences
whatsoever
for the people who misled and lied about
the safety and efficacy of certain
vaccines
no consequences at all in in the federal
government in its associated entities
and in the deep state
great example of this there was a drone
attract attack there have been many
drone attacks in the middle east
so there was a drone attack that the
united states carried out that killed a
bunch of civilians
and it and
the the attack should not have been
launched
and there was an investigation into it
and yep that's bad we killed a bunch of
civilians so the pentagon press
secretary was brought onto a news show
credit where credit's due on to morning
joe and was asked
is anyone going to be held accountable
for this here's his answer
how does it strike you that no one is
held accountable because i know how it
strikes a lot of people around the world
that you can get away with murder and
nobody's punished for it i do understand
that we we appreciate that not
everybody's gonna uh support this
decision uh what i can tell you is we
looked at this thing very very
comprehensively and again we
acknowledged that there were procedural
breakdowns processes were not uh
executed the way they should have been
but it doesn't necessarily indicate that
uh that an individual or individuals
have to be held to account for that but
look uh is there this is their
discipline inside the pentagon at all i
mean maybe there's no charges brought up
but is anyone demoted or disciplined for
what happened then what we are going to
do there's no there's not going to be
individual discipline as a result of
this really but what we are going to do
is learn from this
and we're going to enact and improve our
procedures and our processes to try to
make sure this doesn't happen again
there aren't going to be any
consequences whatsoever for anybody but
we're going to learn from this you're
not going to learn anything if there's
no consequences what are you talking
about
like when you're when your kid keeps
stealing the cookies from the cookie jar
you say okay well i'm not gonna punish
little johnny but he's gonna learn he'll
learn anything no he won't of course and
i'm not suggesting that
the the people who didn't follow the
procedures that led therefore to this
murder of civilians not murder i guess
just homicide generators and the
unintentional killing of civilians
i'm not saying they need to be brought
up on criminal charges i'm not saying
they need to be thrown in prison
in any military operation
there is a risk of civilians being
killed that's that's just what happens
in war this is one of the reasons to be
a little more circumspect maybe when
you're talking about going to war
whether it's an outright full frontal
war or whether it's one of some of these
sort of little wars of empire that the
united states has been engaging in
recently
but surely
surely someone has to be held to account
right surely someone or or multiple
people who didn't follow the rules they
they need at least a slap on the wrist
don't they they need at least to
acknowledge fault don't they
or no
because the blob because the liberal
establishment
never
never faces
consequences
really makes you think there's something
wrong
in america there's something so wrong in
america right now that when you go to
the grocery store and you buy meat that
says product of usa very often it's not
even the product of the usa which is why
you got to check out good ranchers today
is december 17th
and you have not finished your christmas
shopping i know it's okay maybe and you
haven't told your family and your
friends but i know that you haven't i
haven't either you know what i've got a
great gift that you can give at that
would be good ranchers give your family
and friends good ranchers a box of 100
american meat that is steakhouse quality
the quality is off the freaking charts
and i've tried a lot of these types of
services okay
you can give this out wonderful variety
of boxes to give or give it to yourself
even maybe even better you get high
quality beef tender chicken there's the
cowboy where you get the ultimate
steakhouse experience with black angus
ribeyes wagyu burgers and more in the
burgers especially they're all great but
the burgers especially
get 20 off and free shipping on your
order right now with code knowles at
checkout
plus good ranchers is the gift that
keeps on giving
your order keeps local american farms
and ranches open donates 10 meals to
people who'd otherwise go hungry give a
gift they'll remember for years to come
get your friends a good rancher's box or
gift card today tis the season for open
hearts and full stomachs so give good
ranchers with code knolls knwles for 20
bucks off and free shipping that's
goodranchers.com knowles code knowles to
take advantage of this special christmas
offer
speaking of the pentagon
joe biden
was just giving a little update on
what's going on over the pentagon and he
appears to have once again forgotten the
name of the secretary of defense
i want to thank all of our distinguished
guests that are here today
the chairman of the joint chiefs
the the
secretary of the uh of the uh
secretary austin
so it's even worse than just forgetting
the name which he forgot the name of his
own secretary of defense
he also forgot the name of the pentagon
but he also forgot the name of the
department of defense
he said well the and the secretary of uh
what's the what what's fun is it it's
the
not secretary of war
it's not the secretary oh yeah and then
he said secretary austin which he also
had forgotten
so we all we all make fun of joe biden's
uh memory slips and obvious senility
i'm beginning to think this is more sad
than funny
in the in that
if if you've ever dealt with a loved one
who is going through senility whether
it's formally diagnosed as dementia or
not or just age-related memory slips or
just you know a lot of people
a lot of older people go through this
it's extremely sad it's heart-wrenching
to watch
and so i don't know how advanced joe
biden's problems are i don't obviously
they hide him a lot from the public so
we usually don't see these sort of
things they hit him for the entire 2020
election practically
but
for anyone who's ever dealt with a loved
one who is in cognitive decline it's
it's really sad and it's kind of
unpredictable and you don't know when
they're really
capable or not and
this should worry even republicans who
we make fun of joe biden we don't like
joe biden he's always been a doofus from
his earliest most lucid days but
we have a president who is very clearly
not all there i don't mean this in the
way that each party always attacks the
other party and says the president's an
idiot they did this to george w bush
they did it to trump they did they do it
to all the presidents
but i think even for the democrats
listening out there or even the biden
supporters listening out there you can't
tell me that the man is not in a
cognitive decline
and so this raises a question
the question is
do we need a president
there are now some
some conservatives who are saying
we need a basic level of competence and
to run the government if your
president's not competent that's a grave
threat to national security you've got
some disingenuous liberals saying our
president's totally competent it's not a
big deal don't worry about it but i'm
i'm actually kind of open-minded on this
question i don't know that we need a
president really
i i wonder if the administrative state
is so
firm and set and bloated at this point
that it can just kind of run itself
maybe it can i don't know i mean
obviously you need the president to
appoint certain people but really even
those appointments are just made by
advisors and as long as the president
puts his rubber stamp on as long as they
can lift his arm up with a with a pin in
it and just kind of scribble a name on
there then i guess he can sign off on it
do we need a president i don't know
going back all the way to woodrow wilson
you have seen
this this notion develop on the left
that the presidency is too big for one
man and so therefore we need to create
this federal bureaucracy that's just
going to run itself even if the
president is totally incapacitated maybe
that's the case now if that is the case
it tells us that our constitutional
order has changed dramatically from what
it was in the beginning and for for i
guess most of our nation's history to
right now
but it may well be the case that joe
biden can go sit and watch episodes of
matlock and it won't it won't matter the
establishment is pretty effective on its
own you see this not just within the
administrative agencies you see it with
the media too because the media are just
the propaganda arm of of the liberal
establishment and so
for instance
when gas jumps
uh an incredible amount over the past
year it's up i think what 56 or 57
over the past year
and then it drops down
four to 10 cents
an honest news media would come out and
say gosh gas is so high this is really a
big problem it's way way up but but
because the news media are not honest
because they're the propaganda arm of
the liberal establishment they go in
lockstep with the exact same talking
points and say oh wow gas is down less
than 10 cents
huge win great news wonderful great
leader biden doing wonderful all praise
to biden
here at home americans are finally
getting some relief
finally right
good news people we talked so much about
bad news oh my gosh
this is good news gas prices are heading
south down
government forecast forecast says that
they could drop below
three dollars
a gallon
finally some economic relief however
minor americans are paying a little less
at the pump after weeks of rising energy
prices relief for the united states as
energy costs drop that pain that you've
been feeling to the pump it may be
short-lived there is finally some relief
at the pump good news at the pump
finally getting some relief as you
mentioned the national average price of
gas dropped four cents in the last week
gas dropped nearly a nickel in the last
week it's a seven week low it's moving
in the right direction the average is
now at a seven week low actually a seven
week low slightly lower gas prices so
that's good news yeah this is the kind
of positive news we've wanted really
good economic news including dropping
gas prices gas prices will tumble below
three dollars a gallon soon so that's
good news
soon it's gonna happen soon that's the
news the news is a thing that i'm
predicting will happen in the future
because the news of what's actually
going on is so bad and devastating for
the liberal establishment that i can't
even report on that but in the future
i bet it'll be better so that will be
good news
when that
when that happens my favorite one there
is gas prices down almost a nickel
wow really great news huh almost almost
a shiny nickel down the only one there
who even has the impulse to try to be
kind of honest is jake tapper but he's
still got to read all the talking points
because he still works for the corporate
media so he just goes gas prices are
down you know it's only a little big
mr zucker do i really have to okay i do
i guess i do because i'm i'm the
propaganda arm of the liberal
establishment
the media are becoming more brazen
in their
attacks and their defense of the
establishment and their attacks on the
on us the people that they perceive to
be their enemies so joy reid on msnbc
is really upset at elon musk she's upset
because elon musk
was
attacked
on twitter by
elizabeth warren
and so elon musk just keeps trolling
elizabeth warren she says you know you
haven't done anything you're not
productive you're not you're a leech on
society and so that sort of thing and
elon responds and says hey stop
projecting lady and then they keep you
know they keep going back and forth and
he's like hey listen senator karen you
know and he just keeps he's trolling
this lady but
joy reid is very upset because elon elon
musk is not
allowed to use karen which is a racial
slur against
white people white women specifically
because elon musk even though he's an
african-american elon musk is not black
and so he's not he's not allowed to say
that
elon wasn't happy so he did what he
always did and stomped his little feet
and insulted senator warren calling her
an angry mom and referring to her as
senator karen
so for so many reasons being a
freeloader and a selfish and
disrespectful one and for
misappropriating black vernacular for
misogynistic purposes elon musk is the
absolute worst
meanwhile senator warren has better
things to do than fight with junior
birdman on twitter
she's angry with him for appropriating
black vernacular the black vernacular
being a slur against white people
she her response to this is actually hey
you can't use that that's our word
that's our word this would be like
a white person
getting angry at a black person for
using the n-word
and saying hey black people you can't
use the n-word that's our word for you
that's our that's our derisive and
derogatory term for you
you can't do that and that that is what
she's saying about about karen
and she's saying it to an
african-american which is even more
even more outrageous
it shows you also that
racism
if the word means anything anymore i'm
not sure that it does but racism against
white people
is the only acceptable form of racism
and it's not only acceptable and it's
not only legal and it's legal to
discriminate but it's also encouraged
which shows you
that
white privilege is quite the opposite
and it shows you that the races that we
think are oppressed and the races that
we think are the oppressors actually
it's probably the opposite right at
least at least in terms of the culture
and even in terms of the law when you
think about the races that it's legal to
discriminate against in say college
admissions it's white people
and asian people too because they get
lumped in for whatever reason
but but that is some brazen stuff
that is maybe should we i can't we can't
test it out we can't test out the theory
and do it in the other way because
if any white person did that of course
they would lose their job
speaking of race-baiting hypocrites
maxine waters is really
really
pushing the limits
and it you know when you want to when
you really want to
delve into
spectacularly interesting stories such
as what maxine waters does on airplanes
when you want to delve into even more
interesting stories
you gotta check out the jordan harbinger
show we've got a really different and
interesting kind of sponsor for this
episode that would be the jordan
harbinger show which is a podcast you
really have to listen to recently jordan
had on oliver north and the woke mob
really came after him for this he said
that he's been getting attacked just for
doing the interview and i highly
recommend you check it out jordan's show
which apple named one of its best of
2018 is aimed at making you a better
informed more critical thinker so you
can get a sense of how the world
actually works and come to your own
conclusions about what's happening even
inside your own brain
each episode is a conversation with a
different fascinating guest and when i
say there's something for everyone here
i really mean that in one episode jordan
talks to a hostage negotiator from the
fbi who offers techniques on how to get
people to like and trust you which
sounds pretty useful maybe you know a
little worrying but but useful too lots
of science and also some pretty wild
stories from spies and mobsters and art
forgers this guy's got everything i
really love it if that is not worth
checking out i don't know what is we
enjoy the show we think you will too
there is so much there go to
jordanharbinger.com
start for some episode recommendations
or just search the jordan harbinger show
that's h a r b as in boy i n as in nancy
g e r as in really go check it out on
apple podcast spotify or wherever you
listen to your podcasts
maxine waters
is really upset when people don't wear
face masks she's really upset by that
you'll remember last year
she tweeted out quote take a chance
remind an unvaccinated person to put on
a mask and if they get angry you know
just tell them get six feet away from me
keep going she went on tv made the same
exact point
i tweeted something that said if you see
someone that one without a mask uh ask
them
uh if they would like to wear a match
should they be wearing a mask and i said
you're taking a chance and uh if they
get angry just walk away and say six
feet away uh and so um i know that not
everybody believes that they should wear
a mask and the president of the united
states is not helped by not wearing a
mask uh pence the vice president has not
helped uh doing tours and not to wearing
a mask but now i understand that someone
close uh to the president who serves the
president in a you know a staff capacity
is infected and i'm wondering if this is
going to encourage him
more to wear a mask and be a good
example be a good example
that you know not only you asking others
to wear a mask but you're doing it
yourself
to be a good example
you got to be a good example and you
know exactly where the story is going i
don't
you know exactly where this is going
someone yesterday texts me a picture
of maxine waters on an airplane not
wearing a mask
and so we break the story daily wire
breaks the story you can see it it's all
over it's gone viral there she is she's
a hypocrite she's not wearing a mask
i try not to wear a mask on airplanes
unfortunately for me often the
stewardess will come down and say put
your mask on i'm gonna throw you off the
airplane so we have to do it but we're
the little people and then the big
people like maxine waters
they can do whatever they want she
obviously doesn't believe what she's
saying about the masks she's obviously
not afraid of the virus she's she just
wants you to wear the mask now
there are a few levels
here to what the masks are and
the further you go the more clear the
understanding you will have of what the
masks are about
the basic most shallow level is that the
masks are about protecting public health
i just don't think that's true
i think that our rulers
have contradicted themselves on masks
constantly dr fauci did that he said
don't wear the masks the masks don't
work at the height of the pandemic he
said don't wear the mask the mask don't
work then five seconds later he says no
actually you have to wear the masks
then he admitted that he lied about his
beliefs on the masks
then he went and tried to throw out a
pitch at the nationals baseball stadium
and he dribbled the pitch you know it
kind of dribbled to the first base line
and then but he wore the mask on the
pitcher's mound when there was no one
around him and then when he was sitting
up in the stands with his buddies he
took the mask off and was just kind of
hanging out he wasn't really eating he
wasn't really drinking he just had it
off because the masks are extremely
uncomfortable and dumb so
and there have been plenty of other
photos of dr fauci getting caught with
the mask off when he thought the cameras
were not around him and then the cameras
are on him and he puts the mask back on
you see this in san francisco mayor of
san francisco tells everyone they got to
wear the masks and then she goes to a
nightclub and just starts dancing and
doesn't wear the mask because
pelosi got caught liz warren got caught
maxine waters have been caught multiple
times
so i don't think it's about public
health i don't think these people
believe anything that they're saying
it's also not
just about making people wear the masks
i don't think it's quite
that they themselves want to exempt
themselves from a rule that they want
all the other people to follow i don't
think they care if all the other people
wear the masks
when blm was rioting
no one was checking the masks in fact
there were a number over a thousand
public health officials who came out and
said
that
despite shutting down all large
gatherings despite
despite having previously said that all
large gatherings were really bad and
going to spread coronavirus and were
potentially deadly they said
blm protests are good they'll actually
help the public health because white
supremacy is a public health problem
that predates and contributes to covid19
they wrote a whole letter about this
over a thousand of them signed it
so it's not just about making people
wear the masks
it's about making you wear the masks
they don't care if their friends and
supporters wear the masks they don't
care at all
they care if you
their opponents the people that they
perceive as enemies
wear the masks and they are doing it to
make you
comply and submit to their capricious
and arbitrary rule that's what it's
about that's what it's always been about
some of us have been pointing that out
from the very early days
and some people didn't totally believe
that and i i get it we this is a novel
phenomenon but i think now at this point
i don't know how many pictures of
maxine waters and pelosi and voucher and
biden and all these other people not
following their own rules and not
enforcing their own rules on their
supporters you need to see before you
realize the true nature of the mask
as a political symbol
almost entirely divorced from public
health at this point
to make you
submit you have to submit
this is what they are now telling us
openly explicitly jim cramer the the
eccentric stocks guy on cnbc he has
become more vocal about his leftist
political views recently he tweeted out
just a couple days ago quote
government has a right to force you to
obey and has always exercised it
especially under the gop
there are two main reactions to this
tweet both of which are wrong
the libs
are retweeting and saying yes yes slay
queen yes you're so right jim government
can make you obey whatever they want you
better do it and that's that
the
libertarians and i guess a lot of people
on the right but really because of some
of the libertarian premises that we've
taken on over over recent years
they say no the government has no right
to make you obey not a right at all and
they don't oh and they shouldn't
exercise and that's wrong to my body my
choice or whatever they're saying now
even though we don't believe that when
it comes to abortion and other things so
or drug laws even or or any other number
of issues the the real answer here
i'll just edit jim cramer's quote
government
sometimes has a right to force you to
obey and has
sometimes exercised it sometimes under
democrat administration sometimes under
republican administrations
there are just laws and there are unjust
laws first of all going back to romans
going back to paul's letter to the
romans the government is there for our
own good the rulers are there
placed there by if you're a christian
you believe that government is placed
there by god for our own good and that's
very hard sometimes for especially
libertarians to get around to but they
are there for our own good you do need
rule you do need law you do need systems
of government and that's a good thing to
have them
also there are just laws and unjust laws
and it's not always exactly clear quite
where it falls and sometimes a law can
be bad and not great but
still you are obliged to follow it but
sometimes you are not obliged to follow
it this is thomas aquinas 101 this is
political theory 101 and sometimes laws
are so egregious that you are obliged
not to follow it you are actually
obligated not to go along with unjust
laws
and so it requires prudence it requires
thought it requires judgment you can't
put that ideology on the back of a
napkin
and you can't put it in a tweet from a
cnbc
shrieking lunatic but that's the way it
really is
speaking of not complying not only was
the daily wire the first company in the
country to sue the biden administration
for their unconstitutional mandates
we're also less than 100 000 signatures
away from hitting our goal of one
million signatures on the do not comply
petition
reaching one million signatures would
provide a major boost to our legal
challenge we got over 900 000 so far
we need your help to cross that finish
line please sign the petition at
dailywire.com do not comply
then please share the petition
with all of your friends and family in
case you haven't heard by the way ben is
hosting a new exclusive daily wire
series where he catches up with his
closest and most influential friends
for personal and relaxed conversations
when am i going to get the invite i
don't have i haven't gotten the invite
for this relaxed company on a recent
trip to nashville jordan peterson sat
down with ben in a local coffee shop to
start the series off the premiere
episode drops tonight it will be
available only at dailywire.com so if
you're not a member yet now is the
perfect time to sign up go to
dailywire.com subscribe to sign up today
clips of the show will be available on
youtube but you have got to be a member
to watch the whole thing
we'll be right back with the mailbag
welcome back to the mailbag first
question up from philip dearer an author
who has an author has no words knowledge
shapiro did a video listing off the
greatest christmas movies of all time as
someone who actually celebrates
christmas what do you think are the best
movies to watch this christmas season
sincerely all i want for christmas is to
never hear mariah carey again fair
enough
the greatest christmas movie of all time
miracle on 34th street is very good
everyone always says it's a wonderful
life it's actually not that's not my
favorite christmas movie but you know
fine that's fine
home alone i think was the last great
christmas movie i'm not saying it's the
greatest but it's the last really really
great magical christmas movie
and then of course i've got to give you
the the only christmas movie that i have
watched this year re-watched this year
with my wife and that would be jingle
all the way an amazing movie
you've got arnold schwarzenegger
sinbad at the height of his powers phil
hartman
it's a great movie it's genuinely funny
phil hartman is a scream as he always is
it's actually heartwarming it's a great
movie
highly highly recommended from murcia
i hope i'm pronouncing that right dear
michael i'm a big fan of your show and
your book speechless and your podcast
has actually made me return to
christianity in particular orthodox
christianity wow that's cool that's
great
we'll get you over to be catholic soon
enough but i'll tell you orthodox that's
a good good place to get to good place
to start
while i'm very happy with my personal
turn toward faith and conservatism i am
more skeptical about seeing something
similar at a social level against
progressivism
i'm not sure that maybe we're missing a
few words here i'm not quite sure uh is
conservatism just delaying the
inevitable slippery slope to more
extreme liberalism is tomorrow's
republican just today's democrat or are
there reasons to hope for broader social
restoration respectfully yours the
orthodox christian michael
sometimes people misunderstand what bill
buckley said when he said in the first
issue of national review that a
conservative is one who stands with word
history yelling stop at a time when few
if any are inclined to do so
that gives the impression that all we're
doing is
standing a thwart the tides of
progressivism and usually getting kind
of run over or at least backed up into a
corner but we're saying stop stop stop
and we're at least slowing it down
but
what i believe he's referring to there
is the
communist
idea of history capital h the idea you
hear this versions of this when when
leftists use the phrase the right side
of history this idea that history is
unfolding along a very specific logic
and we basically have nothing that we
can do to stop it we can accelerate it
but we can't stop it and
i think buckley is mocking this
communist concept of history as such
so no i don't think conservatives are
merely just saying stop stop stop and
then losing because there's no way to
stop time you know if you to use uh
a chestertonian analogy when you leave
white picket fence alone in a field
you're not going to come back two years
later to a white fence you're going to
come back to a very dirty fence actually
a black fence probably because of all
the dirt and the soot and all the stuff
that's going to be on it right things
are always changing there's no way to
just freeze time
but i do think that conservatives can
offer an alternative
right now it's a little tough because
what passes for conservatism in america
is really usually just a form of
liberalism we accept the same premises
as the as the libs and the progressives
and the leftists for instance that the
individual is the basic unit of society
that's what the libs believe that's what
the leftists believe
they think that the individual is the
basic unit and individuals ought to be
able to do basically whatever they want
and the way to arrange society is by
taking all those atomized individuals
and clumping them together
and
what the
libertarian types on the right believe
is just that we shouldn't clump them
together
that yes the individual is the basic
unit of society but just don't clump
them together and what the conservatives
believe
is that the individual is not the basic
unit of society actually the family is
the basic unit of society
the left believes you're born into
society
with certain abstract rights and it's
we're known primarily by our abstract
rights and they usually list a bunch of
positive rights like the right to health
care and the right to education and the
right to whatever
the libertarians believe we're born with
a bunch of abstract rights and that's
the primary way of viewing our politics
and those are mostly negative rights
life to right to life and liberty and
the pursuit of happiness
conservatives believe that we are born
primarily with obligations i'm not
saying we don't have rights but it's
primarily obligations and duty and
loyalty and filial piety and
and we didn't come in we didn't create
ourselves in this world we're not going
to decide hopefully when we leave this
world and we have obligations to our
families and our communities and
ultimately to our god
you'll notice that the leftists and the
libertarians agree on a lot of basic
stuff which is why we keep losing
because if we're just following the
libertarian strain of things then we're
just going to end up where the left
wants us to
but
if we follow the
conservative way of viewing things
we're going to have very different
premises and we're going to end up in a
very different place
and so my suggestion here is
that american conservatives need to
become much more conservative
and stop
unwittingly buying into the premises of
the libs from sarah
hi michael
i have a childhood friend who was also
my next-door neighbor as young girls we
played almost every day and grew up
together after high school we grew apart
but still remain friends we're now in
our 30s and over the last five years or
so she has come out as transgender okay
she now refers to herself with male
pronouns and has changed her name on a
mask to a masculine one
she's even had her breasts removed oh
gosh it's awful i feel like i'm in
mourning it feels like she died and this
guy is the one who killed her i know
i'll see her this christmas when i visit
my mom's house i know on the inside that
she's still the kind and fun person i
grew up with but i'm having a hard time
with who she is now should i keep this
friendship or should i let it go
well
i would never
suggest abandoning your friends when
they're in the throes of mental illness
or physical illness for that matter your
friend is suffering from
delusions and psychological problems and
probably spiritual problems that are
being compounded by a mass societal
delusion that is reinforcing all of her
fantasies and so that's bad i mean
that's really bad
i have friends who have
a number of friends who have dealt with
mental problems number of friends who've
dealt with physical problems and i don't
think it's good to just abandon them and
say like oh well
you know you had a you had a brain
injury well now i'm not going to talk to
you
oh well you got into a car accident well
now i'm not going to talk to you that's
probably not a good idea
now some of this might not be up to you
because
i don't think that you should indulge
the delusion
i don't think you should say oh how
wonderful it is that you've mutilated
yourself and are are laboring under this
false idea that you're actually a dude
you shouldn't do that
and your friend may
be so far gone
that she she will not be friends with
you if you won't indulge her her
fantasies
so you may end up losing your friend but
i wouldn't be the one to do it i
wouldn't i wouldn't recommend saying
like okay see you darling
i would you know speak the truth with
love that's all we can do
from nigel
hey michael i'm a newer listener to your
show and i was wondering what are some
theological and philosophical literature
maybe books that you find inspiring or
helped shape your world view
oh where do i begin man
where do i
begin edmund burke was very important
reflections on the revolution of france
michael oak shot little essay
rationalism and politics and on being
conservative was really good roger
scrutin is great you can he's got a ton
of great books he has a great movie that
the bbc is suppressing but you can watch
the ripped portuguese version on either
youtube or vimeo it's called why beauty
matters or something like that
owen barfield wrote poetic diction he
was one of the inklings that converted
c.s lewis to christianity that would be
that was a great book
good old uncle aristotle and plato those
are very important writers a dante maybe
maybe more than any writer uh dante
all of his writing but especially the
divine comedy which really shaped my
thought
uh
the bible can't can't forget about the
bible thomas aquinas certainly um
saint augustine
chesterton c.s lewis
i'm just throwing out rant not random
names but i'm throwing out names
seemingly haphazardly because i think if
you if you want to
begin to form or advance informing your
political or theological
thoughts
i don't think it's necessarily the best
way to go about it to just have a list
of books that you have to go down boom
boom boom one after another i think what
you might want to do is
you're reading c.s lewis right you start
you pick up mere christianity or
abolition of man or something and or
whatever from cs lewis and you see that
he references gk chesterton you say
that's interesting and then you go read
gk chesterton for instance right now i
just finished reading drew clavin's new
book his new book is um
on the romantic poets and how it relates
to christianity it's an excellent
excellent book so i'm reading it
and he's referring to the romantic poets
who i have not read took very deeply so
then i go and i order some of the books
from the romantic poets and then i can
go read them so that's what i recommend
doing if you want to expand your thought
from sophia
dear michael i've fallen in love with
the most amazing man we haven't been
dating long but i know i want to marry
him and have all the babies god will
bless us with all right calm down lady
no maybe that's good that's good it's
wonderful to know what you want he's
serious and wants a family i want four
but he wants six the thing is i'm 33 and
he's 45 so time is not on our side oh
yeah
six
i guess probably won't happen
even if you get started right now
but maybe you can get to four
depends how depends how quick you churn
them his business has suffered
tremendously
i know he's waiting until things get
better financially before moving forward
i worry that he may use this as an
excuse not to get married and start a
family what is your opinion on the
long-standing practice of women starting
a family without dot dot necessarily dot
dot planning it with the man first dot
dot dot oh goodness
oh boy i've always been taught that this
is trapping which is wrong uh because
it's dishonest
i think the risk that he would not step
up and marry me if i got pregnant is
basically zero but i feel it may be
morally wrong even though i want i i
even though i know it is something he
wants just not right now
yes that is wrong
that is wrong it's wrong for a few
reasons the the reason that that this
should not be an issue in the first
place is
you shouldn't be sleeping together
before you are married i know it's a
fallen world we all do lots of bad
things i'm not i'm not sitting on my
high horse here and judging you i'm just
saying
this is why this shouldn't be a
possibility even in the first place and
by the way if you guys weren't sleeping
together there's probably a pretty good
chance he would hurry up along with that
with that proposal
but
as the old age-old wisdom goes he is
getting the milk for free and so why
would he buy the cow
especially if he's
maybe got some commitment issues or he's
delaying his maturity
uh but you should not you shouldn't trap
the guy anyway so you're doing this
thing you should probably stop doing it
but if you're going to keep sleeping
together no i don't think you should lie
to him about using birth control and
then trap him i don't think that i don't
think it's great to start a marriage on
deceit and coercion okay i don't think
that's a good idea i would one i would
recommend
cutting that out and then there was a
natural inducement to get married
but then two
if you're not going to do that or even
if you are i would sit him down and say
listen buster you're not getting any
younger neither am i we both want kids
we want to get married so piss or get
off the pot
sorry for the blunt language that's
actually the letter
that's the letter that my grandmother
wrote to my grandfather and they were
pretty young i think they were 22 or
something at the time
but it's good advice
it's good advice and so i will say it
again
despite the slightly salty language
because i think the situation calls for
it
piss or get off the pot that's what you
should tell him to do from verinder dear
michael as a conservative what are your
views on parents smacking their children
i'm not totally opposed to it in theory
i i was spanked maybe a couple of times
as a kid i wasn't not a lot it wasn't a
habit
but so i'm not not totally opposed to it
but in practice i i don't plan on doing
it i hope i don't do it if i do it i
think it would be very
um
rare
i i don't i don't think it's the most
effective parenting strategy
but not not totally opposed to it either
from kyle
hey mr knowles i know people usually
write in to complain about their love
life or the israel wakanda conflict fair
enough
but i have a much more contentious and
divisive question to ask you
what is the best fast food joint in
america if you were on a road trip and
only wanted to see one fast food
restaurant and the at the rest stop what
would it be and what would you order
sincerely came for shapiro state for
nick in the mailbag well
it's a really astute observation that
people write in about their love lives
and you know anything from their love
lives to the israel wakanda conflict
because
the peace in the middle east is often
probably much easier to settle than some
of these questions about people's love
lives uh where would i stop arby's not
even a question we'll do one more
question jessica dear michael so many
millennials and gen z constantly talk
about not worrying about the future and
having faith that things are meant for
you
uh that they won't pass you by there
rarely is any mention of god but it
seems a little bit like faith and i
believe there's a similar bible verse
generally people are referring to
relationships or opportunities when they
mention the things that are meant for
you what are your thoughts on the
sentiment of the things that are meant
for you will find you and if the phrase
is true settling and that's a long
question settling in any aspect of life
out of fear seems like a slap in the
face of god and your faith in him
sincerely the waiting is the hardest
part god is sovereign providence is
extremely real
and
things will unfold according to god's
plan and god can't drive a parked car
and you have free will and you have a
right and an obligation to use your free
will for
the good and you have an obligation not
to be slothful and you got to do stuff
buster and use your reason and your
moral conscience and your courage i'm
michael nolissas the michael knowles
show see you monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 hey
everybody this is andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin